la frágil paz en Sudán vuelve a estar en
peligro después de los últimos
incidentes que comenzaron ayer con los
ataques de las fuerzas paramilitares de
respuesta rápida a instalaciones
castrenses y gubernamentales en la
capital jartung y que ya se han
extendido por todo el país
el reanudación de los combates ha dejado
más de medio centenar de muertos y
cientos de heridos conscientes de una
escalada del conflicto los ministros de
exteriores árabes han llevado a cabo una
reunión de urgencia Hace unas horas en
la sede de la liga árabe en El Cairo
donde han concluido con un llamamiento
conjunto a un alto el fuego por ambas
partes ya que vuelvan a las mesas de
negociaciones para continuar con la paz
Egipto es el país más involucrado en la
crisis de Sudán por su vecindad y por
qué comparten 270 kilómetros de frontera
es por eso que su
Está también manteniendo reuniones con
la Unión Europea en este caso con su
secretario general josep borrell y con
su otro vecino Sudán del sur para mediar
un cese de las hostilidades
Egipto cabe recordar tiene desplegados a
cientos de fuerzas del ejército para
velar por la seguridad y para entrenar a
los soldados sudaneses si escala el
conflicto los militares egipcios se
verían directamente involucrados en los
combates entre los paramilitares y el
ejército regular